also das ist unsere fragenlotterie mit
fiesen fragen und ganz harmlosen oder
höflichen fragen kannst du dir wieder selbst aussuchen
ich möchte lieber gleich wein gib mir
was gutes ja
oh es ist nur dreh es ja
erst die eine seite und dann die andere seite
nur was ja und  dann oh das ist wirklich
cool okay ist es drin oder muss ich
oh nein ich muss okay okay okay ich verstehe
was du sagst ich hab es okay mit
all dem showbiz wie geht es dir immer noch so
natürlich natürlich natürlich uh ich trage
Viel Make-up
ist nicht natürlich, also
reden wir jetzt, aber es ist so
viel unterhaltsamer, vielen Dank, äh,
natürlich, ähm, ich weiß nicht, ich fühle mich wie im
Showbiz. Ich habe es immer als Karriere
gesehen  kein Lebensstil, also ist es einfach für mich
, es einfach beiseite zu legen und
dann mein normales, normales Leben zu
Hause zu führen. Ich habe das Gefühl, dass dies diese Art von
Haus ist
sollte nicht einmal zugeben, dass ich gerne gehe,
oh viel natürlicher bist du  Nun, mein eigenes
als mein normales Leben zu Hause. Ich würde kein
Make-up, keine Haare, ein Durcheinander, aber es ist
nett, dass Sie wissen, wenn Sie
im Showbiz sind, dass Sie ein bisschen aufgeputzt werden
, das macht Spaß und ist Ihre Person  in
meinem charakter
ähm normal natürlich natürlich ist mein
charakter aber ehrlich ich bin sehr ich fühle mich
wie ein sehr natürlicher sehr ehrlicher sehr
unverblümter mensch besonders mit mir selbst und
meinen freunden ich vergraulte alle jungs
weil ich sehr bin  ehrlich und ich sage ihnen,
wie es ist okay nicht gut okay nicht
gut hier warum bist du bist du natürlich
bist du ja ich denke das ist ein
Geheimnis von YouTube du musst
natürlich sein ja um natürlich zu sein musst
du können  auf kein Make-up geh damit ja
du machst wirklich falsche Wände ja sprich
schlecht ein schlechtes Englisch und
fürchte nichts fürchte dich nicht zu sehen das ist
wichtig okay ich werde wie viele muss
ich beantworten bis du
mindestens eine gelesene Frage hast okay  fein
spielen sie ihr spiel was ist das geheimnis
ihres talents als schauspieler und als
musiker  ähm, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube nicht, ich
bin irgendwie in der Industrie aufgewachsen,
aber mein Bruder ist ein Statist, mein Vater ist ein
Statist, mein Bruder ist Musiker, mein Vater
ist Musiker, meine Mutter ist Lehrerin, ich weiß nicht
wie  das passt, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass
ich irgendwie damit aufgewachsen bin und
ich musste zu Menschen aufschauen und sehen, was
sie getan haben, und du weißt, lerne aus ihren
Fehlern oder lerne von dir, du weißt, dass du
vom ersten Tag an perfekt warst  was dabei
herauskam, oh, ich weiß nicht, ähm, ich
fühle mich wie ich und ich habe Musik schon immer geliebt.
Ich liebe Filme und ich liebe es,
Filme zu sehen, und ich schätze, das
hilft irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, also ist es das
Das richtige Leben für
dich, das ist das richtige Leben für mich, ja,
kreativ sein, ich könnte nicht, ich könnte das nicht, den
ganzen Tag in einem Würfel
sitzen  Das ist es,
was ich liebe zu reisen und ich liebe es
, in verschiedenen Umgebungen zu arbeiten
und Touren zu bekommen, wie der beste Teil meines
Lebens, weil ich in einem Bus sitze und  Ich bin mit
meiner Band von meinem besten Freund und du weißt, dass
wir alle zusammen reisen und wir sind
alle zusammen, du weißt, dass wir
zusammen dabei sind und ich denke, das ist
eines der größten Dinge, die ich tue und
ich fühle mich wie  Vielleicht
passt dieser Lebensstil deshalb zu mir, weil ich nicht zu lange an
einem Ort sein
kann  meine Freunde mit mir Ich war
gerade im Urlaub auf den Bahamas
und meine beste Freundin und ich, ich weißt du, haben
sie durch die ganze Stadt mitgenommen, als
ich in New York war, um Interviews und alle
möglichen Sachen zu führen, und es ist großartig,
weil ich es kann  reisen und ich kann mitbringen und
ich bin so glücklich, dass meine Band
mir sehr am nächsten steht
Ohne es zu schließen ist
also echt cool Rockstar zu sein und nicht
so viel Arbeit aber viel Arbeit  in
Wirklichkeit, wenn es Arbeit ist, dann weißt
du, dass du keinen Spaß hast, du bist
aus den richtigen
Gründen nicht dabei  Diese
Art von Arbeit, was würdest du tun?
Ich denke, ich habe immer noch nicht das Gefühl,
einen Job zu haben, weil sich nichts davon wie ein
Job anfühlt, weißt du, dass ich schauspielere, so viel Spaß macht
und es wie ein Spiel ist  ich und
musik oh mein gott musik ist wie das, was ich
immer gemacht habe, es ist ein hobby, also
habe ich mich entschieden, es in meiner freizeit zu tun,
also ist es nicht wirklich ein job, okay, also nein, es ist
besser, es nicht zu wissen  Es nervt,
von Miley Cirus überschattet zu werden, weil
sie ziemlich groß ist, eigentlich geht es ihr gut. Ich
möchte sagen, dass sie immer sagt, sie ist wie
fünf fünf, aber sie ist wie fünf sieben
die Show sie es ist lustig,
wenn du mit einem Jahr
im Fernsehen arbeitest und zwei Schauspielerinnen
an derselben Show arbeiten, die du machen willst  ke sicher,
dass sie sehr unterschiedlich sind, also ist
sie brünett, ich bin die Blondine, sie ist
episch groß und ich bin etwa 1,50 m groß, und
ich muss es sein, ich weiß nicht, wie das
Wetter ist, wie sie da oben sind, aber es
muss anders sein  weil die
Leute mich irgendwie überschwemmen, weil ich
so weit unten bin, aber ich habe das Gefühl, es
gab immer so etwas wie nicht, nie,
Konkurrenz, wir sind einfach so
verschieden vom Lebensstil, sie ist in Tennessee aufgewachsen,
ja, ich bin gewachsen  Oben in LA würde ich
wissen, wie es ist Ich habe schon ewig darin gelebt,
also habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass es so sehr
überschattet wird Ich weiß nicht, weil sie meine
Freundin ist und ich sie unterstütze Ich habe das Gefühl, es
wäre überschattet, wenn ich  Ich war eifersüchtig,
ich war im Neid, was meiner Meinung nach
eine der zwei schlimmsten Eigenschaften ist, die
man haben kann, um neidisch zu sein, ist keine
schlechte Sache, und ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich es wäre,
würde ich versuchen, entweder mit Ihnen zu
konkurrieren  Wenn sie so ist wie sie oder
so, dann würde es sich wie eine Überschattung anfühlen,
weil ich es bin  meine eigene Person
Ich tue
etwas und ich habe irgendwie mein eigenes mein eigenes
Leben am Laufen Ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass es
überschattet wird Ja, ich denke, wir haben eine
lustigere rote Frage lustige richtige
Frage okay
alles klar bis dann okay lass uns deinen
Bruder sehen  wurde für einen Oscar nominiert, ist er
ein besserer Schauspieler, klar ja, klar,
er ist ein besserer Schauspieler, für den er nominiert wurde
, wissen Sie, ich dachte, oh Gott, ich
erinnere mich, dass er aus der Tür ging, um
zu den Oscars zu gehen, als ich dachte, oh Gott, ich
muss.  Ich war acht, ich weiß nicht, ich
saß zu Hause, und wir hatten den
Babysitter, und ich war wie die Pizza am
Laufen. Babysitter kam zur Tür
Als hätte ich keine Ahnung
und er trägt seinen süßen kleinen Smoking und
ich Ramayana ste Ich erinnere mich, dass ich
das schlechteste Gedächtnis hatte, besonders wenn es
um Erinnerungen aus meiner Kindheit geht, und
ich hatte Glück, dass ich viele Tagebücher gemacht habe,
als  Ich war klein, also erinnere ich mich an vieles
, aber ich erinnere mich, dass er aus der
Tür ging und li  Wenn ich so bin, als könnte
ich mich weniger um dich kümmern, schaue ich mir noch einmal Little
Mermaid an, es gibt so etwas
, aber es klingt immer noch so, als könnte
ich immer noch nicht begreifen, dass
es so jung und für einen
Oscar nominiert war und arbeitet  Die sechs Monate waren
unglaublich, also war er ein besserer Schauspieler, huh, ich
weiß nicht, ich denke, das muss das
Publikum entscheiden, äh, okay, okay,
definitiv kein besseres Pingpong von
sonst okay, okay, und Fußballspieler,
was soll ich noch sagen
und ich  Ich bin ein besserer Nein, ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass ich ein besserer Schwimmer herumschwimme. Ich bin ein
besserer. Nein, ich weiß nicht
Ones Ich mag das erste okay sehr
viel oh oh ja ja hast du ein
Privatleben huh Ich fühle mich wie es eine dieser
Fragen ist wo wie ich lügen sollte
SOS wie du weißt ich habe kein
Privatleben ähm aber definitiv ich definitiv ja
Ich habe ein sehr privates Leben mit Ich fühle mich
wie die häufigste Frage, besonders  Aus
irgendeinem Grund ist deine Verletzung ja, ähm,
du hast echte Freunde
wo immer Sie es verwenden können, immer Sie
Berühmtheit wie nein, es ist keine Berühmtheit
oder was auch immer, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich
ständig mit Menschen zusammen bin, die
so normal sind wie ich. Ich bin mit Menschen zusammen,
die normale Aktivitäten, ein normales Leben,
aufs College gehen, es ist so traurig  Alle meine Freunde
sind jetzt auf der ganzen Welt verstreut,
weil sie alle auf dem College sind, aber ähm, ich
weiß nicht, ich habe definitiv das Gefühl, dass es
wichtig ist, besonders in der Branche,
dass wir daran arbeiten, dass es funktioniert und wie schrecklich
es manchmal sein kann und wie  Sie können
so grausam zu Frauen sein, die in der
Branche aufwachsen. Ja, ich denke, es ist so
wichtig, dieses Privatleben zu haben,
das Sie für sich behalten, und
Menschen zu haben, die den gleichen Glauben teilen,
privat zu bleiben, und es gibt einige
Dinge, die Sie tun  mach einfach  Ich rede nicht darüber
, Gott war in Brasilien, sie
reden einfach über alles, worüber sie reden wollten,
weißt du, Sexspielzeug, es war
schrecklich, es war so peinlich, dass ich
saß  von diesen dingen musst du nur
dein privatleben privat halten
ja ja das ist normal in diesem ganzen
business oder ist es normal sich so zu
fühlen oder ist es heute
das private getrennt und das ist nicht die schuld der besagten
person ich meine manchmal  Das Leben Das
Leben in der Öffentlichkeit kann sehr, sehr,
sehr schwierig sein, besonders wenn man
Leute sieht, die Sie kennen, unter Sie kennen
irgendeine Art von Ich weiß nicht, ich werde unter
großem Druck stehen oder kürzlich
etwas durchgemacht haben, das sie wirklich sind  dort wird
das Teleskop, durch das Sie schauen, um sie zu sehen
, ein wenig erhöht, und wir
möchten uns auf ein bisschen mehr konzentrieren, und
wir wissen, wo sie leben und wir wissen,
wo sie einkaufen, wir wissen, wie ihre
Kinder heißen, wir wissen, welche Art sie sind
von Hunden, die sie haben, ist es beängstigend,
es ist sehr beängstigend, dass all deine persönlichen
Dinge wie Ich nicht weiß, also denke ich,
wenn es um Schauspieler geht, besonders
Schauspieler und Musiker sind allgemein, denn
wenn du auf der Bühne stehst, verrätst
du deine größten Geheimnisse  in Liedform, aber
mit Schauspielern Ich liebe es, dass ich Ich weiß nicht
, ich liebe Emma Stone, sie ist unglaublich, ich
weiß nicht, welche Art von Haarprodukt sie
verwendet, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr Hund heißt,
ich weiß nicht  Ich weiß nichts über ihr
Privatleben, ich weiß nur, dass sie eine
großartige Schauspielerin ist, und ich kann sie als diese
Figur sehen, ohne zu sagen, oh ja, das ist,
dass ich ein steinernes Mädchen bin
, das diese bestimmte Art von Auto fährt oder
was auch immer ich davon trennen kann, um mich danach zu
fühlen  Ein Privatleben zu haben ist richtig
, das war keine schwere Frage, warum sie
glauben, dass das grün sein könnte, okay,
es war eine fiese, kleine, fiese Frage, es
war nicht so besonders, weil wir denken, dass Sie
kein Privatleben haben,
ähm, haben Sie ein Privatleben?  Leben, was weiß
ich im Moment nicht über dich  es
wird alle Bomben nehmen und
diesen Spider-Man Superman aufreißen ja ja nein Ich
habe etwas anderes im Moment es ist
schwer manchmal hier ist ein hartes ja aber ich
tue mein Bestes,
mach deine sehr sehr privaten Dinge privat
ja ja gut, aber es ist mehr  eine
frage der zeit ja das ist eine ok
frage der zeit wir haben ein privatleben
es oh ja das ist zeit zu mögen geben oh
mein gott vertraue es ist ja da
stimme ich dir voll und ganz zu weil
du so hart arbeitest offensichtlich ja
und  und du versuchst,
hier dein Bestes zu geben, aber du willst auch
zu Hause mit deiner Familie und so etwas dein Bestes geben
, also ist deine
Zeit manchmal aufgeteilt und du musst auf
einige wirklich tolle Dinge verzichten  du
musst zwei personen sein manchmal zwei leute ja
was wäre dein aliasname entschuldigung
dein aliasname wie wäre dein anderer
name ich weiß nicht wirklich wenn du
zwei personen hast musst du zwei namen haben okay ich
denke darüber nach du '  werde darüber nachdenken
ok alles klar ok  Ich danke Ihnen vielmals